heute ist ein historischer tag in
deutschland denn seit heute wird endlich
auch in deutschland geimpft es hat
länger gedauert und schon jetzt zeichnet
sich ab dass es erneut probleme geben
kann denn es gibt zumindest am anfang
nicht genügend impfdosen was macht das
mit deutschland was macht das impfen und
was bedeutet es für die menschen darüber
möchte ich sprechen bei die richtigen
fragen
[Musik]
christian lindner fdp parteichef und
fraktionsvorsitzender erwin rüddel der
cdu politiker und chef des
gesundheitsausschusses im bundestag und
gerd landsberg der chef des städte und
gemeindebunds herzlich willkommen und
großartig dass sie es einrichten konnten
so kurz nach weihnachten
herr lindner ich möchte direkt anfangen
mit etwas was mich bewegt hat an diesem
wochenende und zwar geht es um die lkw
die in nordrhein westfalen auf der
straße waren unter sieht man wie die
ersten lkw über die autobahn fuhren und
dann dort im lager ankommen und dann mit
ausgepackt und da sieht man da ist gar
nicht so viel drin in diesem riesen lkw
nämlich nur zwei man muss sagen
lächerliche kartons und dann sieht man
wie das ausgepackt wird das soll
eigentlich eine große show darstellen
das ist gefilmt worden vom land in nrw
in düsseldorf und man hat das auch bei
twitter geteilt ganz stolz sozusagen
diese szenen aber was geht ihnen durch
den kopf wenn sie da diesen riesen lkw
sehen und dann sind da nur zwei kartons
sind
das wirkt natürlich unfreiwillig komisch
und vielleicht ist das auch symbolisch
idee lkw zeigt die größe der erwartung
das was dann tatsächlich an impfstoff
transportiert wird zeigt die realität
die nämlich weit hinter den erwartungen
zurückbleibt und darüber werden wir in
den nächsten tagen und wochen auch
sprechen müssen woran liegt das
naja also sehr spät sind die
bestellungen durch die bundesregierung
angepasst worden sie wissen dass kurz
vor weihnachten noch 30 millionen dosen
zusätzlich bestellt worden sind sehr
spät als andere natürlich ihre
bestellungen schon abgeschlossen hatten
und zum zweiten muss man den hinweisen
des bayerischen ministerpräsidenten
söder nachgehen der heute ja dargelegt
hat dass aus seiner sicht das
produktions tempo in deutschland erhöht
werden muss dass die kapazitäten
ausgedehnt werden müssen
und ich habe eine dritte komponente ich
meine wir müssen die haus- und fachärzte
stärker noch in den prozess mit
einbeziehen
haben kontakt beispielsweise zu
gefährdeten menschen älteren menschen im
regulären austausch in der praxis also
sollten die auch nicht nur attest
aussteller seien sondern alt möglichst
auch impfen von der logistik spricht
dann nichts dagegen harel sie sind chef
des gesundheitsausschusses sie kennen
sich aus sie sind enger vertrauter auch
von jens spahn dem
bundesgesundheitsminister wenn sie die
bilder dort sehen aus nrw da fühlt man
sich doch komplett verarscht also ich
denke das ist ein zeichen der hoffnung
und der zuversicht anfang und wir werden
jeden tag jetzt in der nächsten zeit dem
ende der pandemie näher aber aber er
würde mir deshalb was ist oder warum ist
das ein zeichen der hoffnung wenn man
ein lkw sieht wo lediglich zwei kartons
drin sind man will das gros inszenieren
und am ende zeigt sich wir haben nicht
genug impfstoff verunsichert dass die
bevölkerung also ich bin mir sicher dass
heute sehr viele menschen schon geimpft
worden sind wir sind vorbereitet die in
zentren stehen die mobilen impf teams
die stehen in den pflegeeinrichtungen
sind heute die ersten menschen geimpft
worden wer hätte vor drei vier monaten
geglaubt dass wir noch in diesem jahr
mit ihm fünf beginnen
aber es hat man also los britannien und
den usa sind ja schon hunderttausende
geimpft warum sind wir in deutschland so
spät obwohl der impfstoff hier
entwickelt wurde
also wir setzen auf solidarität
wir wären nicht so weit gekommen wenn
wir nicht solidarisch
in der politik in der eu in der
forschung zusammen gestanden hätten und
deshalb starten wir gemeinsam und wir
starten nicht mit einer note zulassung
sondern wir starten mit einer regulären
zu mit als mit einer regulären zulassung
und das gibt auch den menschen
sicherheit dass wir hier es mit einem
sicheren impfstoff zu tun haben der alle
qualitätsmerkmale erfüllt hätten finden
sie das richtig wenn wir nach
großbritannien schauen da ist man ja
fast neidisch und denkt sich wieso sind
da schon so viele männer
geimpft und am ende muss man ja sagen
das ist sind menschenleben die schon
gerettet wurden warum sind wir in
deutschland so spielt dran und haben da
nicht mal genug also da müssen wir vom
tempo aufholen in den nächsten tagen und
wochen das ist ja völlig klar weil sonst
die bevölkerung ungeduldig wird wenn
geimpft wird dann wird auch gleichzeitig
die bereitschaft abstandsregeln
einzuhalten zurückgehen also werden wir
müssen tempo aufholen aber eins ist
völlig richtig hat die regierung absolut
korrekt gemacht nämlich nicht eine
notfall zulassung national zu machen
sondern auf eine europäische zulassung
eine reguläre zulassung zu setzen
notfalls zulassung bedeutet ja dass ein
impfstoff nicht in der weise geprüft
worden ist wie bei einer regulären
zulassungen wir können jetzt den
menschen auch sagen es ganz wichtig für
die impfbereitschaft
es geht nicht um experimente mit
menschenlebens ist ein regulär
zugelassener impfstoff der hier verimpft
werden kann
das kann man wenn man sich dafür
entscheidet ohne größere bedenken auch
das aber nochmals zu produktionen wenn
sie jetzt sagen das muss schneller gehen
wenn wir das mit den historischen
schicksals jahren vergleichen was wir in
den vergangenen 100 jahren erlebt haben
die kanzlerin hat gesagt die pandemie
das ist etwas was wir hat es sozusagen
mit dem zweiten weltkrieg hat gesagt das
es seit dem zweiten weltkrieg so eine
krise nicht mehr gegeben hat braucht es
dann auch besondere
produktionsbedingungen jetzt für diesen
impfstoff das würde ich bejahe markus
söder hat ja ausgesprochen dass die
produktionskapazität erhöht werden
müsste und dem ist nun zuzustimmen
man muss allerdings sagen herr uns aber
dass natürlich die unternehmen bei und
tag selbst ein eigeninteresse haben
möglichst viel zu produzieren
denn es werden wettbewerber auf den
markt kommen dann ist der vorteil von
biontech irgendwann weg es heißt die
wollen natürlich jetzt sehr viele
produkte politischen auch tun wenn man
zum beispiel sagen hier in der
produktion
und dennoch ich würde jetzt nicht
kriegsproduktion sagen wir sagen von es
ist ein krisenhafter zustand aber auch
wir eine krisen produktion und da ist
natürlich denkbar dass ein impfstoff
auch von anderen herstellern in lizenz
produziert wird nun ist dieser impfstoff
an sehr kompliziertes verfahren ist also
nicht einfach aspirin das irgendwo in
lizenz produziert
das ist voraussetzung voll aber wir
sollten alle voraussetzungen rechtlich
wirtschaftlich politisch technologisch
treffen damit schneller in diesem jahr
geimpft werden kann
das ist eine frage wie sie zurecht sagen
von leben und tod ist eine frage unserer
freiheit und es ist eine überlebensfrage
auch für unsere wirtschaft denn die ist
schon auf der internetseite kann man
ganz konkret sie sagen krisen produktion
wie kann man ganz konkret jetzt sagen
wir müssen so schnell wie möglich so
viel wie möglich produzieren was kann
man da tun
da sehe ich zuerst mal herrn söder der
dieses thema ja als regierungschef auf
die politische tagesordnung gebracht hat
in der pflicht er sollte sich mit
beispielsweise herrn sparen im bund
zusammen setzen aber am sieg meine idee
ja aber das ist zunächst mal die
zuständigkeit der verwaltung weil man
muss die verträge kennen die die
regierung abschließt man muss die
standorte kennen wo produziert wird und
deshalb würde ich sehr begrüßen wenn die
regierung mit der pharmazeutischen
industrie in deutschland insgesamt prüft
wo gibt es noch kapazitäten die genutzt
werden können für die produktion eines
impfstoffs wohlgemerkt es geht nicht um
die enteignung von bayern tag sondern um
die frage können wir zusätzliche
kapazitäten mobilisieren um für dieses
unternehmen im lizenz zu produzieren
bevor wir den landsberg
wie kann man die produktion steigern was
können wir tun damit schneller
produziert wird damit mehr menschen
schneller geimpft werden können also wir
hatten in der anfangsphase ja das
problem welcher impfstoff wird
letztendlich zum erfolg führen da haben
wir auf risikostreuung gesetzt gott sei
dank ist bei montech dabei moderner in
einigen tagen und ich bin zuversichtlich
dass wir in einigen wochen in eine
situation kommen dass die hausärzte
einsteigen können in den impf prozess
und das ist vier bis sieben
unterschiedliche impfstoffe gibt dadurch
dass ein hausarzt seine patienten auch
entsprechend beraten und im volk an und
ich bin zuversichtlich und das ist ja
alles schon auf den weg gebracht dass
also die hausärzte denke ich nach wahl
in die lage versetzt werden zu impfen
und wir werden jens spahn hat das ja
schon aufgegriffen
wir werden versuchen mehr kapazitäten an
uns
und wir werden wege finden dass also die
kapazitäten ausgedehnt werden da bin ich
zuversichtlich jetzt wo wir wissen
welche impfstoffe erfolgreich sind
werden wir auch wie
um die menschen schnell zu ihm herr
landsberg sie haben den überblick über
die kommunen über die städte in
deutschland jetzt hat man schon gehört
in den ersten am ersten tag heute
er hat es in bayern zum beispiel nicht
so richtig funktioniert da gab es schon
probleme was ist ihr überblick wie hat
der erste tag funktioniert bei der
impfung also eigentlich ist es genauso
gekommen wie wir erwartet haben wir
hatten gesagt am 15
dezember stehen die impfzentren 440 im
zentrum stehen wir haben auch gewusst
dass es am anfang bis ende des jahres
etwa 400 600 1000 impfdosen nur geben
wird wir haben festgelegt welche
altersheime werden in welcher
reihenfolge angefahren vor den mobilen
teams und die große masse des impfstoffs
wird erst in den ersten monaten des
jahres 20 21 kommen bisher gehen wir von
etwa 13 millionen aus bis ende februar
das ist eine beachtliche zahl die ja
auch erst mal verimpft werden muss und
deswegen will ich ein linda recht geben
wir müssen sehen wenn es einen weiteren
impfstoff gibt der nicht diese kühl
anforderungen hat dass wir die hausärzte
viel intensiver einbinden nur mal eine
zahl im letzten jahr haben die hausärzte
in deutschland über 20 millionen
menschen gegen grippe natürlich das wird
immer mal schwierigkeiten geben es wird
immer mal rocken aber ich finde bisher
ist das eigentlich ganz gut gelaufen
aber sie sagen sehr selbst es gibt
momentan nicht genügend impfstoff obwohl
bei und tag in deutschland sitzt wer
soll das verstehen
also ich glaube das kann man schon klar
machen wir haben hier europäische
solidarität geübt und haben gesagt der
impfstoff der vorhanden ist der wird
verteilt zwischen den eu-ländern nach
einheitlichen kriterien ich finde das
gut das ist ein signal von solidarität
und ich befürchte ehrlich gesagt am ende
etwas anderes nicht dass wir zu wenig
impfstoff haben sondern dass die
bereitschaft in der bevölkerung sich
auch schnell impfen zu lassen vielleicht
nicht so ausgeprägt ist wie wir das
erwarten können deswegen plädieren wir
als deutscher städte- und gemeindebund
dafür jetzt eine kampagne aufklärung was
bedeutet die impfung was
rückt sie denn es ist ja jetzt auch in
der bevölkerung so das gefühl also bin
ich geben dass alles gut nein so ist es
nicht immunität hat man nach der zweiten
impfung auch erst nach wochen das heißt
die monate januar februar werden nach
sehr hart und auch danach wird es für
viele menschen noch abstand maske das
wird noch weiter gelten bis zum sommer
aus meiner sicht wenn sie dass das jetzt
zumindest nicht so viele menschen zu
beginn geimpft werden können wie die
menschen sich wünschen also es gibt mehr
leute die geimpft werden möchten
es gibt nicht genügend impfstoff das
muss man ja mal so klar sagen verstehen
sie das wenn sie sehen dass dieser
impfstoff in deutschland produziert
wurde
ja ich bin wie herr landsberg wie ich
glaube die ganz große mehrheit in
unserem land der auffassung dass wir
verantwortung in europa tragen dass wir
auch vielleicht sogar eine globale und
aber warum hat man nicht nur einfach
mehr bestellt und jetzt kommen wir zu
dem punkt dass biontech in deutschland
entwickelt und in die welt liefert nach
europa liefert damit habe ich kein
problem
ich sehe bei uns die politische
verantwortung jetzt darin alle
möglichkeiten der pharmazeutischen
industrie zu nutzen um die produktion
auszudehnen wäre es dann so die
kanzlerin der gesundheitsminister wer
hat das verbockt das müssen sie als
journalistin einordnen ehrlich gesagt
interessiert mich jetzt vor allen dingen
die wir schnell das problem lösen denn
ich sehe die massiven sozialen und
wirtschaftlichen folgen dieses lockt
dieser pandemie in der rückschau wird
man möglicherweise sagen dass die
sozialen und wirtschaftlichen
folgeschäden genauso groß oder stadt
sogar größer waren als die
gesundheitliche risiko situation der wir
müssen schnell aus der situation herr
bei allen schulen zu haben können wir
später seine schuld von aber am ende
geht es ja um leben und tod
es ist toll dass menschen sterben war ja
auch nicht genug impfstoff gibt und
deshalb lassen sie das auch ganz konkret
sagen wir müssen die
produktionskapazität wo es möglich ist
erhöhen
wir müssen mehr bestellen auch beim mehr
herstellern
ich habe nicht die sorge wenn wir jetzt
bei allen produzenten unterschiedliche
impfstoffe in großem umfang bestellen
nach dem motto wer liefern kann möge
bitte liefern
dann haben wir am ende vielleicht etwas
übrig behalten
deutschland haben wir zu viel bestellt
aber lieber zu viel weil man streut
bestellen
auch in großem umfang das können wir
dann auch noch in der welt anderen
bedürftigen geben
die frage haus und fachärzte da sind wir
hier im studio jetzt einer meinung das
muss nur vorbereitet werden das muss
schneller gehen
da kann auch der biontech impfstoff
übrigens genutzt während es im
kühlschrank eine zeit lagerbar wir haben
die labor logistik ja die jeden tag
blutproben transportiert das geht ganz
flott da braucht man nicht diese
kühlkette in der sehr niedrigen
temperatur wie bei den impfzentren und
ich will ein landsberg recht geben
wir müssen die impfbereitschaft in der
bevölkerung aufrecht erhalten oder
möglicherweise noch erhöhen es gibt ja
zahlen dass nur 57 prozent jetzt bereit
sind sich impfen zu lassen und der
schlüssel dafür ist eine informations
und akzeptanz kampagne nicht
werbefilmchen sondern klare aufklärung
was ist das für ein impfstoff was sind
das für impfstoffe wie sind die
nebenwirkungen ab wann tritt eine
wirkung 1
ich glaube da ist die regierung jetzt
gut beraten auch durchaus mit zb den
medien zu sprechen
wie können wir kapazitäten nutzen nicht
jede zeitung hat jede seite gegenwärtig
bedruckt weil die wirtschaft so viel
wirbt da kann die regierung eintreten
also bild ist jede seite druck muss ich
dazu sagen herr lauterbach schätzt dass
bis ende märz lediglich sieben prozent
der bevölkerung geimpft sind muss das
nicht viel schneller gehen wenn man
bedenkt dass wirklich jeden tag menschen
sterben können und wie ja wahnsinnig
hohe zahlen also mir ist jetzt nicht
bewusst war lauterbach die zahlen her
hat das sind
klose ich bin der festen überzeugung
dass wir mehr menschen geimpft haben
werden wir haben alle vorbereitungen
getroffen
das was herr lindner gesagt hat ist
richtig dass also die zwei bis drei tage
auch der biontech impfstoff bei normalen
kühl temperaturen gelagert werden kann
wir haben die logistik für die ärzte
also ich bin der festen überzeugung wenn
karneval vorbei ist aber wann damals
latex bis wann haben wir dann
herdenimmunität das wollen die leute
dort wissen wir haben erden immunität
wenn mindestens 60 prozent der
bevölkerung geimpft ist ist er ich bin
der festen überzeugung also nach meiner
meinung wird das also vor der
sommerpause sein dass wir dieses ziel
erreicht haben
ich hoffe sogar schneller geht weil halt
auch produktionskapazitäten erhöht
werden
piontek hatte in marburg eine neue
produktionsanlage eröffnet das was also
herr lindner fordert das ist alles schon
auf den weg gebracht die zahlen heute
zeigen dass also die impfbereitschaft in
den pflegeeinrichtungen und auch vom
pflegepersonal von den pflegebedürftigen
buch ist 90 prozent 70 prozent und
deshalb glaube ich dass wir auf der
einen seite von der logistik her von der
produktion her zügig vorankommen und von
der impfbereitschaft hier auch preislich
werden die schnelligkeit an würde da
möchte ich gerne jemanden mit in die
sendungen dem der das vorgemacht hat das
ist eher kramer der chef des zentrums im
harz da ist er kann man sie haben ja
eigentlich schon gestern allen die show
gestohlen
als sie einfach losgelegt haben wie ist
das passiert ja wir haben gestern
angefangen zu impfen weil wir den
impfstoff geliefert bekommen haben und
einsatzbereitschaft bestand sowohl
personell als auch materiell und für uns
gibt es und gab es keinen grund noch
zuwarten und in dem stoff den
bevölkerungen vorzuenthalten
jetzt war der bundesgesundheitsminister
so ein bisschen pikiert hat gesagt naja
eigentlich wollten wir alle zusammen
starten
was empfinden sie bei der kritik wissen
sie wir arbeiten hier für unsere hart
zur bevölkerung für die menschen die
hier leben und nicht für einzelne
politiker den startschuss geben wollen
oder ein bändchen durchschneiden
das ist unsere verpflichtung und den
wollen sie auch nachkommen haben sie das
gefühl dass die politik das so ein
bisschen als schon jetzt nutzen wollte
heute die die den im staat also ich sehe
zumindest keinen medizinischen oder
logistischen grund hier ein solches 10
obert zu veranstalten sondern wir sind
so aufgestellt wenn wir die
einsatzbereitschaft haben wollen wir
auch loslegen hier ist eine sehr hohe
motivation in den team- und auch bei der
bevölkerung sie haben sie eben auch
gesagt die bevölkerung auch hier möchte
die im verein hat ein großes interesse
und daher sehen wir es tatsächlich nicht
ein den impfstoff vorzuenthalten nur
weil eine pressekonferenz anberaumt
sie sagen da gibt es eine hohe
motivation und bereitschaft sind sie
enttäuscht dass nur so wenig impfstoff
zu ihnen gekommen ist ich denke das ist
ein wachsender prozess wir erwarten
wöchentlich weitere lieferungen für uns
ist es aus der logistik gesehen zunächst
mal ganz in ordnung mit den mengen die
wir erhalten haben natürlich wäre es
wünschenswert wenn wir breiter
bevölkerungsteile auch erreichen wurden
zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
und wenn sie sich die diskussion jetzt
anschauen in deutschland was ist ihr
gefühl wie hoch ist die impfbereitschaft
bei uns in deutschland
also ich kann es nur sagen aus den
pflegeeinrichtungen alten einrichtungen
in denen wir im moment waren die
meldungen die an uns gehen liegen bei
circa 80 bis 90 prozent impfwilligen in
den einrichtungen und auch der
mitarbeiter
das scheint etwas höher zu sein als im
bundesdeutschen durchschnitt oder den
umfragen entsprechend daher hier im harz
ist der wunsch sehr groß auch an diesen
impfstoff zu kommen
zum abschluss der kammer erklären sie
uns noch mal wie dramatisch ist die
situation in den altenheim in den
pflegeheim was erleben sie da tagtäglich
also wir sehen natürlich den großen
wunsch der bewohner und auch der mitte
weiter den impfstoff zu erhalten alle
sind tatsächlich davon überzeugt und sie
haben bis heute sehr positives feedback
bekommen für den start den wir im märz
gezeigt haben dass jeder tag wirklich
zählt und wir müssen auch einfach daran
denken dass wir es den leuten auch
erklären müssen warum hier impfstoff
künstlich zurückgehalten wird wir müssen
vielleicht auch die frage stellen warum
waren niemand anderes bereit diese
entscheidung zu treffen sehr frühzeitig
zu beginnen wenn der impfstoff vor ort
ist herr lindner sie hören ist von vor
ort
was ist ihr eindruck wenn sie das hören
und wenn sie sozusagen auch die worte
von ihren sparen gestern wahrgenommen
haben
der direkt eigentlich ein kramer und
diejenigen die im harz dort geimpft
haben kritisiert hat ich finde herr
kramer hat das aus der praxis so
nüchtern und so frei von
parteipolitischen interessen formuliert
das kann man einfach nur so stehen
lassen
wer trägt die verantwortung am ende wenn
man sagt es gibt nicht genügend
impfstoff und der kam hat ja auch gesagt
er versteht nicht warum das nicht
vielleicht schneller gegangen ist wer
trägt am ende die verantwortung wenn
menschen sterben wenn sich menschen
infizieren gerade in alten- und
pflegeheim obwohl impfstoff schon da
sein könnte also diese diese dramatik
die sie in der zuschreibung jetzt tote
in alten aber jeder tag kostet
menschenleben werden
das stimmt aber ich mache niemanden den
vorwurf jetzt vorsätzlich
gesundheitliche schädigungen es geht ja
nicht um vorsätzlichkeit ist dann die
frage ob am ende auch die politik
verantwortung übernehmen muss werde ich
impfstoff zu spät kommt natürlich müssen
alle verantwortung übernehmen nur um die
kirche im dorf zu lassen muss man schon
sagen
im historischen vergleich von der
entwicklung eines impfstoffs bis hin zur
herdenimmunität in unserem land wird das
ohne beispiel seien in der gesamten
geschichte ich will so weit gehen zu
sagen der menschheit und insofern muss
man jetzt bei der zumessung von schuld
und verantwortung insofern relativieren
dass er relativ schnell schon sind sage
ich selbst als oppositionspolitiker im
bund dennoch das haben wir eben
gesagt muss man ernst nehmen wenn ein
ministerpräsident das bin nicht ich
sondern ein ministerpräsident sagt die
produktionskapazitäten können
ausgeweitet werden dann bitte möge das
geschehen wenn er selber sagt das muss
sein und das kann gelingen dann
bitteschön sollen den worten jetzt taten
folgen sondern sich mit herrn sparen
zusammensetzen überlegen was kann
geschehen und wir werden kritisch prüfen
müssen ob tatsächlich hinreichend viel
von der bundesregierung bestellt worden
ist ich habe zweifel daran dass
untersuchungsausschuss nein braucht es
nicht
das ist ein politisch wollen sie das
dann in der nächsten legislaturperiode
bin ich für einen der scheine ja nur
dann wenn man unter untersuchung anklage
versteht ich verstehe unter
untersuchungen dass wir gemeinsam in der
gesellschaft lernt für die nächste
pandemie und ich möchte frau merkel und
herrn sparen nicht auf eine anklagebank
sehen sondern ich möchte dass wir
gemeinsam für eine nächste pandemie
gerüstet sind sie kann kommen und
deshalb bin ich in der nächsten
legislaturperiode für eine
enquetekommission das also eine
kommission die nicht wie nicht nicht mit
der strafprozessordnung zeugen vor lädt
sondern wo gemeinsam mit experten wenn
man wenn man nicht mehr weiter weiß
gründet man arbeitskreis wir möchten
einmal hörte ich finde ich zu unernst
falls ein wichtiges thema und wie gesagt
ich werfe niemandem vor in einer solchen
krisensituation auch ein fehlurteil zu
unterliegen das muss später korrigiert
werden das einzige wo man vorwurf machen
muss die das enorme überbordende
selbstbewusstsein manches
regierungsvertreters passt nicht zu den
dann handwerklichen mängel in meiner
schätzungen
naja beispielsweise er hat uns herr
sparen immer gesagt seit dem frühjahr
schon die altenheime sind geschützt man
unternimmt alles und da muss ich
wirklich sagen wir haben es immer wieder
im bundestag verbunden ist mein zeuge
bei jeder corona beratung gesagt unsere
alten pflegeeinrichtungen sind eben
nicht geschult das wollen wir es einmal
anders und ich weiß schon was er sparen
konkret gesagt hat zu der frage wie
altenheime geschützt sind oder nicht
geschützt er hat gesagt natürlich haben
wir uns besten möglich in allen
bereichen vorbereitet auf das was kommen
kann wir sind seit frühjahr dabei
bestmöglich die pflegeeinrichtungen zu
schützen herr lindner bestmöglich und
ein so viele tote die vielen hinweise
auf defizite in der praxis sind ganz
offensichtlich oder haben ganz
offensichtlich nicht dazu geführt dass
entsprechend gehandelt worden ist ich
will hat ich kann nur von uns sagen wir
haben als als konstruktiver teil der
opposition im bundestag im frühjahr
gesagt wir brauchen ffb zwei masken in
einer krisen produktion
wir müssen diese masken anwohner gruppen
aus geben es muss eine ffp zwei masken
pflicht in pflegeeinrichtungen geben wir
brauchen schnellstmöglich
testmöglichkeiten auch im sinne einer
schleuse beim zugang in
altenpflegeeinrichtungen
und zwar nicht nur für besucher sondern
für beschäftigte bis hin zum catering
bis hin zur reinigung und all das kam
spät sehr spät aber noch mal ganz
konkret zu dem zitat was glauben sie
geht menschen durch den kopf die jetzt
in diesen tagen in diesen wochen denn
ein familienmitglied verloren haben in
altenheim und pflegeheim ist das nicht
hohen wenn der gesundheitsminister sowas
sagen ich will die debatte mit ihnen so
nicht führen
herrn spanien eine direkte verantwortung
linie aber es war schon der unterhalts
müssten sterben heranzubringen ja aber
trotzdem viel verantwortung wenn er das
ja trotzdem finde ich nicht seriös und
sie bringen mich jetzt paradoxerweise in
die situation die regierung verteidigen
zu müssen weil der vorwurf so drastisch
ist den sie machen ich machen
vorgestellt nun fragt ja aber sie wissen
was ich meine
ich kann nur sagen es hat dringende
ratschläge an die regierung auch von uns
gegeben
sie sind spät befolgt worden und nach
vorne gerichtet kann ich jetzt nur
erneuern unsere nationale
kraftanstrengung trotz der impfung muss
darin bestehen die besonders gefährdeten
menschen zu schützen als ein baustein
auch um wieder soziales und
wirtschaftliches leben zu eröffnen
wir sind ja vollkommen einer
perspektivlosigkeit hertel hat schon
sehr optimistisch was ich begrüße gesagt
bis sommer herdenimmunität aber was
passiert denn bis dahin hatte bis dahin
die gastronomie und ich wirtschaft
geschlossen vor wir darüber sprechen wir
ich möchte gerne noch einmal bei dem
zitat bleiben und herrn kramer
wieder mit ins gespräch nehmen er kam
mir was geht ihnen durch den kopf wenn
sie das lesen was den
gesundheitsminister gesagt hat ja das
ist sie genau das beispiel was ich hier
immer gerne auch als praxisfern
betrachter es wird schnell vom
schreibtisch aus solch eine aussage
getroffen ohne hier vor ort gewesen zu
sein ohne dass man sich ein bild gemacht
hat und ohne dass tatsächlich das bild
in den einrichtungen und bei der
bevölkerung eingefangen wurde
wir sehen dass tatsächlich anders für
uns zählt jeder tag und daher kann ich
daher so nicht mitgehen ich habe da aber
tatsächlich auch kein keine probleme das
ist eine äußerung die uns von unserem
handeln hier vor ort nicht abhalten wird
für unsere bevölkerung heraus zu
arbeiten
sie sind parteikollege von herrn sparen
sie haben sind chef des
gesundheitsausschusses ist wenn sie das
lesen bestmögliches getan um alten und
pflegeheime zu schützen finden sie das
auch das ist ein bruch dem wir versucht
haben gerecht zu werden und auch oft
gerecht bock geworden sind wir befinden
uns kann man denn den eine wir auch bei
der beschaffung von impfstoff hätten ja
im sommer zu hundert prozent auf buy und
heck gesetzt hätten wir heute mehr
impfstoff aber ich glaube was in ihren
verleger heimisch und empfingen nach nur
die frage der inneren es nicht die 800
erfüllt hätte und dann hätten wir heute
nichts das heißt man muss kompromisse
machen man muss es gedreht wurden alten
und pflegeheime bestmöglich geschützt
wir haben versucht diesen weg zu gehen
wir haben mit testen angefangen wir
haben mit masken angefangen jetzt im
moment werden die pflegeeinrichtungen
als erstes die menschen dort geimpft wir
werden wie herr lindner es gesagt hat
ich hoffe sogar noch zum ende dieser
legislaturperiode überprüfen müssen
waren wichtig welche schritte waren
falsch welche schritte waren zu langsam
um vorbereitet zu sein
auf eine neue pandemie die immer mal
wieder kommen kann
aber das was wir hier durchlaufen das
durchlaufen ihr das erste mal das ist
doch eine experimentelle phase und aus
diesen dieser experimentellen phase
müssen wir auskommen
für die nächste pandemie und erfahrungen
sammeln also eher vorwürfen zu machen
ich höre jeden tag jeden tag gottseidank
lebe ich in deutschland und muss diese
an bmi weltmeister sind wir nicht mehr
wenn wir uns die zahlen anschauen und
die statistiken da geht die jet aviation
immerhin ist erst einmal sehen wie sich
zu dem thema integration in deutschland
so gewählt worden
ich möchte gerne noch einmal
frau schwesig hören mit der ich vor der
sendung sprechen konnte was die
ministerpräsidenten von mecklenburg
vorpommern zum impfstoff zu sagen hat
ich habe die sorge dass wir nicht
genügend impfstoff um rechtzeitig da
haben wir liegen jetzt los und nochmal
ich gehe davon aus dass die
bundesregierung dafür sorge trägt denn
das war von anfang an die verabredung
der bund besorgt den impfstoff und wir
länder müssen mit den kommunen vor ort
in vier zentren bereitstellen die
mobilen teams und heute haben wir
losgelegt in den pflegeheimen darüber
bin ich sehr froh denn es ist schon ein
zeichen auch der hoffnung und zuversicht
dass wir uns damit schritt für schritt
aus der pandemie befreien können die
ministerpräsidenten von
mecklenburg-vorpommern ist eigentlich
kritischer als sie oder ich hab eben ja
gesagt das in meinen augen zu spät und
nicht genug impfstoff beschafft worden
ist herr spahn hat ja erst am 23 12
nochmal 30 millionen dosen bestellt sehr
spät ich hätte im sommer nicht
exklusiver bei und tag gesetzt sondern
auch auf andere impfstoffe aber
angesichts der milliarden schäden in der
wirtschaft und auch der gesundheitlichen
risiko situation hätte deutschland
einfach sehr viel mehr bestellen müssen
sehr viel mehr über den eigenen bedarf
hinaus
notfalls hätten wir diesen impfstoff
dann an andere bedürftige in der welt
verschenkt aber jetzt fehlt uns
möglicherweise zeit weil das bei den
impfstoff nicht stimmt und es ist ja ein
signal dass mit herrn söder und frau
schwesig jetzt zwei regierungschefs aus
den ländern diesen zweifel äußern
herr söder den hinweis gibt die
produktion muss ausgeweitet werden
und darum kreist ja unsere sendung hier
ich wills jetzt nicht ein weiteres mal
wiederholen
jetzt muss man sich mit der
pharmazeutischen industrie an den tisch
setzen in einer krisen produktion und
muss überlegen wie können wir vielleicht
nicht oder spät erfolgte bestellungen
kompensieren durch eine erhöhung der
produktion und da sehe ich an sparen
schon in der verantwortung als ressort
minister
genau diesen runden tisch mit allen
akteuren der pharmazeutischen wirtschaft
jetzt anzustreben herr landsberg
herr lindner sagt wir brauchen
schnellere produktion krisen produktion
wie sehen sie das
also da muss man bedenken dass wir in
den impfzentren natürlich eine
beschränkte kapazität haben wir haben
die 440 15 drin da können pro tag etwa
2000 in hamburg sagt man 2700 personen
geimpft werden auch später können wir
die hausärzte einbinden aber bei dieser
masse wird es da eine grenze geben
insofern glaube ich diese diskussion
über die zahl der impfdosen ist
vielleicht nicht so bedeutsam wie es
hier jetzt in dieser sendung dargestellt
wird ich will gerne noch was zu den
altenheim sagen also diese information
von einer lauterbach kann ich so nicht
wir gehen davon aus dass bis ende
februar die alten und
pflegeeinrichtungen geimpft sind und
dass wir dann auch relativ bald einen
deutlichen rückgang der sterbezahlen in
diesen einrichtungen haben und das ist
ein ganz wichtiges signal aus meiner
sicht auf das wir nicht nur hoffen
sondern dass wir auch erwarten
parallel glaube ich müssen wir auch
jetzt schon mehr für diese einrichtung
tun das sagt sich immer so leicht die
müssen da alle ein schnelltest machen
häufig fehlt es an personal und deswegen
werden wir versuchen zusätzliche
freiwillige zu gewinnen
die jedenfalls in den altenheimen die
bedarf haben helfen um diese
sprechen schnelltests zu ermöglicht aber
herr landsberg das klingt doch warten
also ich meine wieso gibt es dann nicht
mehr in zentren wenn sie sagen es gibt
dann ich bin den platz warum
überlegen sie mal es müssen ja da auch
leute da sein die impfen die
gesundheitsämter sind an der grenze
ihrer leistungsfähigkeit ist es uns
gelungen für die impfzentren mit den
kassenärztlichen vereinigungen 10.000
ärzte zusätzlich zu gewinnen und tausend
andere freiwillige helfer die eine
gewisse vorbildung haben muss also wir
haben einfach keine unbeschränkten
kapazitäten diese pandemie ist neu sie
ist furchtbar aber ich finde so schlecht
haben das bisher nicht gemacht
aber länder das klingt jetzt nicht so
als wenn man optimal vorbereitet ja
vorbereitet waren wir nicht aber wir
sind jetzt ja bald auch ein jahr in der
pandemie und das als einen impfstoff
geben wird war auch länger bekannt und
deshalb ja gut dass er mit den
impfzentren jetzt beginnen
aber im grunde müssten doch sofort jetzt
die kapazitäten der niedergelassenen
ärztinnen und ärzte genutzt werden
das geht auch mit diesen impfstoffen der
ihn in hinreichender qualität
hoffentlich bald bekommen
da sehe ich keinen grund warum wir
weiteren vorzug haben die
kassenärztliche bundesvereinigung selbst
also die niedergelassenen ärzte selbst
haben ja kritisiert dass sie nicht schon
frühzeitig nicht jetzt schon einbezogen
sind also da gibt es ganz offensichtlich
eine bereitschaft die die
kassenärztliche bundesvereinigung zum
ausdruck bringt also nehmen wir die doch
beim wort und nutzen wir dort die
kapazitäten nicht nur noch ein satz zum
testen in den altenpflegeeinrichtungen
sagen herr landsberg hat völlig recht
mit der beschreibung der problematik
dass es natürlich personelle engpässe
gibt und dass wir auch deshalb schon an
grenzen bei den test stoßen
aber hier ist dort die frage zu stellen
ob wir erstens noch weitere kapazitäten
mobilisieren können ich glaube dass etwa
die bundeswehr noch zusätzliche
möglichkeiten hat auch im bereich der
vorgebildeten reservisten ist nicht
ausgeschöpft die kapazität und zum
zweiten ist die frage zu stellen ob bei
den tests also ich war sie ob sie haben
ja schon mal an stellt er das gemacht
wie ich
also ich glaube mit einer gewissen
medizinischen unterweisung die nicht
lange dauert es wären auch wir beide in
der lage notfallmässig mal einen test
durchzuführen
sprich das muss kein medizinisches
fachpersonal sein dass an der schleuse
eines altenheims die tests sollten alles
schon auf dem eg8 und geregelt ja aber
herr wurde ich muss sagen sie alles auf
den weg gebracht ist doch alles in allem
also den bislang haben wir sehr schonend
mit der regierung in kairo drei vier
wochen sind der regulierung aber wenn
sie jetzt zum fünften mal sagen nach
zehn monaten alles ist auf den weg
gebracht und wir uns die tatsächliche
situation ansehen werde ich langsam
etwas ungehalten und vergesse meine
vornehmheit nichts läuft so gut wie die
regierung darstellt da mache ich keinen
vorwurf daraus weil wir in einer
schwierigen lage sind aber die
fortwährende beschwichtigung alles ist
so toll was soll denn diese störenden
hinweise der opposition
wenn die regierung im sommer unsere
hinweise auch schutz der bullen gruppen
ernst genommen hätte dann wäre
möglicherweise dieser krasse locker und
im winter sogar vermeidbar gewesen
denn die hohen zahlen haben wir
insbesondere bei betagten und
hochbetagten reden sie die lage einfach
nur schön ich weiß welche beschlüsse
gefasst worden sind und das was herr
lindner angesprochen hat ist alles schon
vor zwei drei wochen veröffentlicht
worden auf den weg gebracht worden dass
wir auch hinein kritisiert dass die
regierung schon auf den weg gebracht hat
also hier trainiert dann nicht wenn wir
wenn wir uns die situation aus dem
notwendigkeiten da waren aber ich kann
jetzt nicht dass kritik was die
regierung schon vor drei vier wochen
erkannt hat und auf dem die erfolgreiche
achter vielleicht da wir noch mal alles
geben zu den altenheimen weil herr
linder die bundeswehr angesprochen hat
wir haben in deutschland etwa 15.000
einrichtungen der altenpflege
wenn die nur jeweils zwei personen
brauchen um bei den schnelltest zu
helfen sind das 30.000 personen die hat
die bundeswehr dafür nicht sie kann
sicherlich noch mehr helfen aber ich
glaube wir brauchen mehr
freiwillige unterstütze ausdrücklich was
er gesagt hat das kann nach einer
gewissen anlernen phase auch jemand
lernt er jetzt nicht medizin studiert
hat oder eine ausbildung im
medizinbereich
ich möchte noch einmal zu einem anderen
thema kommen natürlich corona aber
angesichts sozusagen der impfung des
ersten tages vergisst man so ein
bisschen dass wir immer noch im lok down
sind und wenn wir jetzt in den nächsten
tage schauen da gibt es am 5 januar
wieder eine sitzung jetzt hat heute
horst seehofer in der wams gesagt dass
der locker und nach dem zehnten januar
unverändert weitergehen wird auch wenn
die zahlen rückläufig sind und wenn die
zahlen so bleiben wie jetzt aktuell dann
müssten härtere maßnahmen ergriffen
werden herr lindner härtere maßnahmen
meine befürchtung ist die regierung hat
eben keine dauerhaft durch haltbare
strategie impfung schutz der besonders
gefährdeten menschen einrichtung von
luftfiltern im öffentlichen raum in
schulen all das ist teilweise auf den
weg gebracht aber mitunter auch im tempo
griechische landschildkröten unterwegs
und wir verlieren viel zeit nicht nur
für den schutz von von menschen sondern
wir verlieren natürlich auch zeit um
enormen schaden von unserer wirtschaft
abzuwenden aber er mag den härtere
maßnahmen ab 10 januar glaube ich lange
ich das noch erwarte dass wir noch sehr
lange in der jetzigen situation sind
aber ich verfolge werden bis märz sprach
schon einmal der kanzleramtsminister
müsste man diese situation fortsetzen
also das ist meine erwartung aber meine
politische forderung ist dass wir im
grunde die nationale kraftanstrengung um
das wort von frau merkel noch einmal zu
verwenden
darauf konzentrieren die menschen die
ein besonderes krankheitsrisiko haben zu
schützen da sind ja auch die schweren
krankheitsverläufe da ist die auslastung
der intensivmedizin die gefahr der
triage das haben wir alles dort und
nicht bei den jüngeren damit wir eine
perspektive für die menschen bekommen
das im frühjahr schnellstmöglich wir
schritte in eine veränderte
verantwortbaren normalität gehen der
rille lockdown bis märz
hin und zurück halten müssen sicherlich
bis märz das heißt aber nicht dass das
in der gleichen weise erfolgen
derzeit ist wir werden sicherlich bis
ende war anfang 40 nach allen gruppen in
den pflegeeinrichtungen geimpft haben
wollen dass also eine überforderung
unseres gesundheitssystems nicht
eintritt und das ist ja der grund für
den walk down und je mehr menschen
verbundgruppe geschützt sind desto
freier können wir uns eben das heißt
aber nicht dass nach dem 10
januar wieder alles ganz normal ist hier
aber man kann sich schon einmal an den
schulen und geschäfte wieder komplett
offen wann sind schulen und geschäfte
wieder auf ich halte es für äußerst
wichtig dass die schulen nach dem
zehnten sind es wieder geöffnet werden
und ich könnte mir vorstellen da so
gegen ende januar wir was entwickelt das
ist alles prognose das hängt davon ab
auch wie wir uns über weihnachten über
neujahr insgesamt verhalten haben
verhalten werden ob die brücke des
lockouts da sind davon hängt ab wie die
maßnahmen nach dem zehnten aus sehen wir
uns an die regeln halten desto weniger
einschränkungen haben wir in der zukunft
und ich möchte noch einmal ich möchte
anderen vorschläge öffnen und dass die
kinder in die schule möchte noch einmal
frau schwesig hier einspielen
sie hat auch eine meinung dazu was mit
dem lockdown passieren soll
wir sind ja verabredet mit der
bundeskanzlerin
januar unter werden uns die zahlen
anschauen müssen die niedrigen zahlen
jetzt über die feiertage
müssen wir wirklich vorsichtig sehen der
scheint wir wissen dass über die
festtage weniger getestet wird auch
weniger menschen zu testen gehen und
deswegen wird es oft die zahlen nach
diesen feiertagen ankommen ich gehe
davon aus dass wir die maßnahmen
verlängern müssen denn wir sind noch
nicht durch und wir müssen deutlich
unter einer inzidenz von 50 kommen damit
wir wieder in bessere fahrwasser sind
und das wird noch eine lange strecke der
impfstoff gibt hoffnung und zuversicht
darf uns jetzt aber auch nicht
leichtsinnig machen wir müssen weiter
strenge maßnahmen alle zusammen
einheiten und dazu gehört vor allem dass
ab heute ja gilt dass die weihnachts
regel vorbei ist sondern wir uns wieder
nur im ganz kleinen umfang sehen können
mein rat ist in den nächsten tagen
wirklich zu hause zu bleiben kontakte zu
meiden es ist jetzt besser sich
zurückzuziehen und dann auch gesund ins
neue jahr zukommen incidents unter 50
ist das überhaupt realistisch wenn wir
uns nur an der 50 und der frühe der 35
sogar orientieren dann werden wir sehr
lange nicht aus diesem kompletten
lockdown in deutschland heraus finden
das kann nur ein indikator sein die zahl
der inzidenz es ist auch zu fragen wer
infiziert sich hochbetagte menschen oder
sportive junge menschen ohne
vorerkrankung
wir müssen schauen wie ist die
auslastung im intensivmedizinischen
bereich das hängt unmittelbar auch mit
der frage der demografie also der frage
wer infiziert ist zusammen konkret
gesagt wir werden kontakt beschränkungen
weiter brauchen maske tragen müssen auf
hygiene achten müssen
eine corona waren app in verbesserter
funktion weiter miteinander nutzen 2
funktioniert doch einfach überhaupt
nicht sagte er in verbesserter form
2 ich bin dafür dass wir regional
konsequente maßnahmen einleiten wo sie
nötig sind aber wenn an der nordseeküste
die zahl der incidents viel niedriger
ist als in niederbayern
dann muss es da unterschiedliche
herangehensweise geben also regional
geschäfte wieder öffnen
natürlich wenn die regionale incidents
runtergeht oder sozusagen die
ampel von rot auf gelb springt muss das
ja eine auswirkung haben idealerweise im
sinne einer wenn dann regel damit man
weiß von 199 steigt auf 200 in einem
landkreis kommen automatisch bestimmte
maßnahmen könnte man übrigens der waren
es dann auch ortsbezogen ausgeben hätte
einen hohen nutzwert für die menschen
der dritte punkt den ich ansprechen will
ist dass wir wie hier in der sendung
besprochen mit dem impfen fortfahren und
zugleich trotzdem die variablen gruppen
schützen
und dann haben wir eine perspektive dass
im januar nicht die ganze gastronomie
aber anteil nicht vielleicht der ganze
handel überall aber doch einen teil
wieder öffnen kann
es muss ja einen blick in die normalität
zurück geben herr lanz zurück in die
normalität ich war in den letzten tagen
in meiner heimat in ostfriesland in
aurich und bin dadurch die fußgängerzone
gelaufen die der inzidenz wert ist
glaube ich unter 20 da verstehen viele
menschen nicht warum die geschäfte
geschlossen sein müssen und wenn man da
natürlich die stadt geht hat man das
gefühl dass gerade mittelgroße städte in
deutschland massiv leiden werden dass
viele geschäfte schließen müssen
was kann man tun also das ist richtig
beschrieben wenn das so weiter geht
werden sie die innenstädte vieler städte
und gemeinden nach der korona krise
nicht mehr wiedererkennen
deswegen plädiere ich auch für eine
vorsichtige öffnung meine prognose am 5
januar werden die ministerpräsidenten
und die kanzlerin entscheiden dass das
bis 30 januar verlängert wird aber dann
brauchen wir zusätzlich eine strategie
wie wird wann wo gelockert das ist eine
erwartungshaltung der menschen was sie
beschrieben haben ist völlig richtig
wenn sie in einem kreis oder einer stadt
zwanzig oder dreißig oder vierzig
neuinfektionen haben dann sehen die
leute nicht ein warum sie nicht
einkaufen sollen also wir müssen viel
langfristiger denken und stadt immer zu
sagen jetzt kommt es noch härter glaube
ich dass es wichtig ist die schnelltests
strategien auszubauen nicht nur im
altenheim in der schule im kindergarten
das ist aus meiner sicht ein viel
vernünftiger weg und ich bin
hoffnungsvoll dass die politik diesen
weg auch gehen
aber das bringt wie kann man die
innenstädte retten was muss getan werden
neben der öffnung haben sie die sorge
dass sozusagen der online-handel da
jetzt alles übernimmt was glauben sie
was kann man noch tun
also ich glaube wir müssen eine andere
strategie haben wir brauchen eine aktion
rettet die innenstadt
dazu gehört deutliche aufstockung der
städtebaufördermittel die zeit des
reinen handels in den innenstädten ist
vorbei wir brauchen mehr kultur mehr
kunst mehr gastronomie aber das kostet
geld auch wenn ein anker kaufhaus zum
beispiel leer steht muss die kommune in
die lage versetzt werden dort das zu
kaufen umzuwandeln
auch mehr grün gehört in die städte und
ich glaube dass es auch sinnvoll wäre
nachzudenken ob der online handel nicht
zum beispiel über eine art paket steuer
diese infrastruktur die er nutzt auch
mitfinanzieren muss sie wissen es gibt
diese überlegungen wir als deutsche
städte und gemeindebund unterstützen
dass herr in ihre kanzlerin die
kanzlerin hat immer wieder dafür
geworben noch härter vorzugehen immer
wieder gesagt dass das nicht gereicht
hat in den letzten wochen und hat ja mit
ihren prognosen was die was die
infektionszahlen angeht auch richtig
gelegt aber haben sie das gefühl dass
das so weitergeht oder glauben sie dass
bei der kanzlerin auch so ein bisschen
einsetzt wenn man in landsberg hört was
das ganze für konsequenzen leben hat für
innenstädte für den handel für die
geschäfte
also wir müssen eine balance finden
zwischen uns unserer das sind auch die
innenstädte und den gesundheitsschutz
und ich bin auch der festen überzeugung
wir brauchen mehr differenzierung in den
markt und da wo als die inzidenz niedrig
ist da wo man sich an regeln hält halte
ich also eine öffnung für notwendig
einfach auch um die entsprechende
akzeptanz herzustellen auch das
verhalten zu belohnen
und da wo die inzidenz zu hoch ist da
müssen maßnahmen länger in einer
gewissen verpflichtung beibehalten
werden da wo schon ziemlich viel wieder
offen ist möchten wir uns auch mal
anschauen was auf den ski pisten in den
vergangenen tagen los war
da sehen wir bilder wie sozusagen der
vermeintliche harte locker und aussieht
in österreich und in der schweiz
volle lifte die menschen sind auf den
skipisten und man hat dort heute
insbesondere bilder gesehen da jetzt
nicht unbedingt dicht gedrängt aber hier
sehen wir viele menschen aufeinander er
lindner würden sie jetzt tief angehen
nein aber das skifahren mit abstand wäre
ja nicht das problem sondern eher après
ski und die berühmten partys in ischgl
die zum urlaubserlebnis oft auch dazu
gehören trifft jeder andere sportart
genauso man kann alleine skifahren oder
damit der partnerin dem partner
man kann tennis spielen zu zweit man
kann golf spielen was eben nicht möglich
ist ist dass man gesellig zusammen
bleibt frau schwesig hat völlig recht
wir müssen kontakte reduzieren das ist
ein gebot der stunde und zugleich aber
auch eine voraussetzung krieg dem herrn
rödl und herr landsberg da auch beim
wort dass wir schnellstmöglich da wo es
möglich ist auch wieder zu einer öffnung
kommen denn selbst die viertgrößte
volkswirtschaft der welt wird es nicht
schaffen auf dauer mit öffentlichen
geldern die private wirtschaft in gang
zu halten wir werden im nächsten jahr
massive schäden in unserem
schafft überhaupt erst sehen durch die
maßnahmen der regierung vertagt auf die
zeit nach der bundestagswahl
aber ich prognostiziere für das dritte
und vor allem das vierte quartal
nächsten jahres in wirtschaftlicher
hinsicht leider ein böses erwachen
eine nächste bundesregierung wird alle
hände voll zu tun haben nicht nur den
staatshaushalt aus dem schuldensumpf zu
befreien sondern auch eine
wirtschaftliche erholung mit der
sicherung von arbeitsplätzen
anzuschieben herr landsberg zum
abschluss der mann über den wir heute
auch durchaus kritisch gesprochen haben
bundesgesundheitsministerin sparen ist
heute in einer umfrage erstmals vor
merkel gerückt 52 wollen dass er eine
möglichst große bedeutung in der politik
künftig hat können sie sich jetzt sparen
als bundeskanzler vorstellen
selbstverständlich kann ich mir einen
amtierenden bundesminister auch als
bundeskanzler vorstellen
das ist aber doch ganz normal die
menschen sehen den jeden tag im
fernsehen viele dinge machte aus meiner
sicht auch gut das kommt medial gut
rüber sie haben das gefühl es geschieht
was früher hat sich für den
gesundheitsminister
nur eine minderheit interessiert also
das ist eine momentaufnahme die sei ihm
gegönnt aber ob das nun langfristig
trägt aber den mal zwei fragezeichen
machen
entspannt kanzlerkandidat
ja ich halte ihn für fähig diese
aufgaben zu übernehmen
ich halte ihn nicht erst seit heute
dafür fähig sondern schon eine geraume
zeit ich bin davon überzeugt dass er der
richtige mann am richtigen platz derzeit
ist es gut durch die pandemie geführt er
hat die entsprechenden reformen im
gesundheitssystem auf den weg gebracht
und ich glaube dass er große aufgaben
noch für deutschland lösen kann und auch
wäre wenn wir über ihren sparen reden
glauben sie dass die diskussion ums
impfen ihm jetzt schaden wird stützt
seinen umfragen ab oder glauben sie er
hat eine chance kanzler zu werden
also ich glaube nicht dass er
kanzlerkandidat wird da spricht gar
nicht gegen seine qualität das müssen
andere beurteilen bin nicht hier
zensuren zu geben aber
meine erwartungen prognose wie die
innere bewegung in den unionsparteien
ist ist dass er nicht kanzlerkandidat
wird ich glaube an die werte verdient
diese 52% ich bin unsicher bei dieser
umfrage in der umfrage rang wäre ich ja
vor den parteispitzen der grünen
das ist ungewohnt für sie passt zu mir
ist es nichts wenn man die umfrage der
parteien vergleicht grünen und der fdp
dass ich als fdp-vorsitzender vor beiden
spitzen der grünen sein sollte deshalb
habe ich ein bisschen zweifel was die
aussagekraft dieser umfrage angeht aber
einerlei
für mich steht jetzt nicht nur das
krisen-management im vordergrund sondern
auch auf welcher wert grundlage mit
welchen politischen kompass macht jemand
politik und es ist bekannt dass ich jens
spahn persönlich sehr schätze
wenn ich aber seine gesundheits und
pflegepolitik auch die pläne die er in
der nächsten zeit geäußert hat oder für
die nächste zeit geäußert hat dann habe
ich zweifel ob er tatsächlich ein
anhänger der sozialen marktwirtschaft
ist wie ich sie verstehe friedrich merz
beispielsweise hat sie ja um nicht nur
fdp kritik zu äußern friedrich merz zum
beispiel hat ja sie entschieden
ausgesprochen gegen die pflege
vorstellungen von herrn spahn er
steuermitteln weil das die bewährte
anlage unserer sozial versuchte
friedrich merz ganzen einig soll ich
will nur sagen das uneingeschränkte lob
für den politiker jens spahn teile ich
so nicht ich schätze ihn persönlich aber
als politiker das bewährte konzept
unsere sozialversicherungen auf beiträge
zu setzen und nicht auf steuern das in
frage zu stellen halte ich für falsch
ist auch nicht die traditionelle
cdu-politik warum eine über beiträge
finanziert sozialversicherung die ist
nicht so anfällig für die wünsche der
politiker wahlgeschenke zu verteilen
weil nämlich die arbeitnehmer und die
arbeitgeber sie bezahlen müssen über
eine steuerfinanzierung kann man ganz
schnell in eine unsolide situation
kommen leider vertreter sparen diese
haltung ja nicht glaube für die
versicherung brauchen wir eine eigene
sendung wahrscheinlich herzlichen dank
erstmal für heute herzlichen dank herr
landsberg herzlichen dank herr riedel
und herzlichen dank herr lindner dass
sie sich zeit genommen haben zwischen
den jahren an einem sonntag hier über
das wichtige thema impfen zu diskutieren
und wir bei bild informieren sie
natürlich weiter in den nächsten tagen
wie viele impfdosen jetzt tatsächlich
kommen ob es im chaos endet oder ob mehr
produziert wird
[Musik]